(Música)
En un día típico de escuela,
se pierden interminables horas
aprendiendo a responder preguntas,
pero justo ahora, haremos lo contrario.
Nos centraremos en preguntas de las que
no hay respuestas por aprender
porque se desconocen.
Cuando niño solía interrogarme sobre muchas cosas,
por ejemplo: ¿qué se sentiría siendo un perro?
¿Sienten dolor los peces?
¿Qué hay de los insectos?
¿Fue el Big Bang sólo un accidente?
¿Existe un Dios?
De ser así, ¿cómo asegurarnos
que es Él y no Ella?
¿Por qué tanta gente inocente y animales
sufren cosas terribles?
¿En verdad hay un plan trazado de mi vida?
¿Está por escribirse el futuro?
O ¿ya está escrito, sólo que no podemos verlo?
¿Pero si tengo libre albedrío? Es decir,
¿quién soy a fin de cuentas?
¿Acaso soy una máquina biológica?
¿Entonces, por qué soy consciente?
¿Qué es la conciencia?
¿Serán los robots conscientes algún día?
Quiero suponer que algún día
me dirán las respuestas a todas estas preguntas.
Alguien debe saberlas ¿no?
¿Pues qué creen? Nadie sabe.
La mayoría de estas preguntas
me confunden ahora más que nunca
pero bucear en ellas es emocionante,
porque te llevan a la frontera del conocimiento
y nunca sabes qué hallarás ahí.
Entonces, dos preguntas:
preguntas que nadie en la Tierra tiene la respuesta.
[¿Cuántos universos existen?] (Música)
A veces cuando voy en un largo viaje de avión,
miro fijamente todas esas montañas y desiertos
e intento meter en mi cabeza
la vastedad de la Tierra.
Entonces recuerdo que hay un
objeto que a diario vemos
en el que cabría un millón de Tierras enteras:
el Sol, que parece imposiblemente grande.
Pero en el gran esquema de cosas, es una insignificancia,
una de casi 400 mil millones de estrellas
en la galaxia de la Via Láctea,
que puedes ver en una noche clara
como una pálida neblina blanca
extendida en el cielo.
Y se pone peor. Quizás hay
100 mil millones de galaxias
detectables por nuestros telescopios.
Si cada estrella fuera del tamaño
de un grano de arena,
tan solo la Via Láctea tendría suficientes para llenar
una playa de 10 por 10 metros
por un metro de profundidad de arena.
La Tierra entera no tiene playas suficientes
para representar las estrellas de todo el universo.
Una playa así se extendería por cientos
de millones de km.
Bendito Stephen Hawking, eso es
un montón de estrellas.
Pero él y otros físicos ahora creen en una realidad
que es inconcebiblemente más grande todavía.
Es decir, primero que nada, que las 100 mil millones de galaxias al alcance de nuestros telescopios
son probablemente una fracción minúscula del total.
El espacio mismo se está
expandiendo a paso acelerado.
La vasta mayoría de las galaxias
se separan de nosotros tan rápido
que su luz quizá nunca nos alcance.
Aún así, nuestra realidad física aquí en la Tierra
está íntimamente conectada con
esas galaxias invisibles, distantes.
Podemos pensar en ellas como
parte de nuestro universo.
Constituyen un solo y gigante edificio
que obedece las mismas leyes físicas con
los mismos átomos: electrones, protones,
quarks, neutrinos, eso de lo que estamos
hechos tú y yo.
Sin embargo, recientes teorías de la física,
también la llamada teoría de cuerdas,
nos dicen que podría haber
infinidad de otros universos
compuestos de tipos de partículas diferentes,
con propiedades diferentes,
que obedecen leyes diferentes.
La mayoria de estos universos no podrían
sustentar nunca la vida,
y podrían existir en un abrir y
cerrar de un nanosegundo.
Aún así, combinados forman un vasto multiverso
de posibles universos de hasta 11 dimensiones,
que presentan maravillas más allá de
nuestra más desbocada imaginación.
La versión imperante de la teoría de cuerdas
predice un multiverso
formado de 10 a la 500 universos.
Esto es un uno seguido de 500 ceros,
un número tan vasto que si cada átomo
en nuestro universo observable
tuviera su propio universo,
y todos los átomos en todos
esos universos tuvieran cada uno
sus propios universos, y repitiéramos eso
por dos ciclos más, tendríamos todavía
una diminuta fracción del total, esto es,
14 veces un trillón (1 seguido de 18 ceros)
de un trillonésimo.
Pero incluso este número
es diminuto comparado con otro número:
infinito.
Algunos físicos piensan que el espacio tiempo continuo es cabalmente infinito,
que contiene un número infinito de los
llamados universos de bolsillo
con propiedades variadas.
¿Cómo está su cerebro?
La teoría cuántica agrega una arruga entera más.
Esto es, la teoría ha sido probada
más allá de toda duda,
pero su interpretación es inquietante,
y algunos físicos piensan que para
poder apaciguarnos
si imaginamos que ese enorme número
de universos paralelos
se está propagando a cada momento,
y muchos de estos universos serían en efecto
muy parecidos a nuestro mundo,
e incluirían múltiples copias de uno.
En uno de tales universos, te graduarías con honores
y te casarías con la persona de tus sueños,
y en otro, no tanto así.
Bueno, todavía hay algunos
científicos que dirían: disparates.
La única respuesta significativa a la pregunta
de cuántos universos existen es uno.
Sólo un universo.
Algunos cuantos filósofos y místicos
discutirían que incluso nuestro
propio universo es una ilusión.
Entonces como puedes ver, ahora mismo
no hay consenso en esta pregunta, ni de cerca.
Todo lo que sabemos es que la respuesta
está en algún lugar entre cero e infinito.
Bueno, creo que sabemos algo más.
Estamos en una era de lo más
fabulosa para estudiar física.
Quizá estamos experimentando el cambio de paradigma más grande del conocimiento,
que la humanidad haya visto.
[¿Por qué no podemos ver la existencia de vida alienígena?] (Música)
En algún lugar allá afuera en el vasto universo
seguramente hay infinidad de otros
planetas repletos de vida.
¿Pero por qué no vemos evidencia de ello?
Bueno, esta es la famosa pregunta
hecha por Enrico Fermi en 1950:
¿Dónde están todos?
Teorías conspirativas afirman que
los OVNIs nos visitan a cada rato
y los informes simplemente se ocultan, pero honestamente, no son nada convincentes.
Pero eso deja un acertijo real.
El año pasado, el observatorio espacial Kepler
encontró cientos de planetas
cerca de estrellas cercanas.
Si extrapolan esos datos,
parece que podría haber
un mil millones de planetas
en nuestra propia galaxia.
Si una en 10 mil tiene condiciones
que pudieran sustentar una
forma de vida, eso es además
50 millones de posibles planetas
que alberguen vida
justo aquí en la Vía Láctea.
Aquí el acertijo: nuestra Tierra no se formó
hasta pasados cerca de 9 mil millones
de años tras el Big Bang.
Infinidad de otros planetas en nuestra galaxia debieron haberse formado mucho antes,
dando ocasión a la creación de vida,
miles de millones o ciertamente muchos millones
de años antes de que ocurriera en la Tierra.
Si solo en unos cuantos de ellos
se propagó vida inteligente
y empezaron a crear tecnologías,
esas tecnologías habrían tenido millones de años
para crecer en complejidad y poder.
En la Tierra,
hemos visto la drástica aceleración que puede lograr
la tecnología en sólo 100 años.
En millones de años, una civilización
alienígena inteligente
podría fácilmente haberse diseminado por la galaxia,
quizá creando artefactos recolectores de energía
o flotas de naves colonizadoras
o obras de arte gloriosas
que inundan el cielo nocturno.
Al menos, pensaríamos que nos revelarían
su presencia, deliberadamente o no,
mediante sus señales electromagnéticas
de algún tipo u otro.
Y aún no vemos evidencia convincente de ello.
¿Por qué?
Bueno, existen numerosas respuestas posibles,
algunas muy oscuras.
Quizá una sola civilización superinteligente
ha tomado en efecto la galaxia y
ha impuesto un estricto silencio radial
porque tiene paranoia de competidores potenciales.
Está sentado ahí listo para anular
cualquier cosa que sea una amenaza.
O quizá no existe esa inteligencia,
o quizá la evolución de una inteligencia
capaz de crear tecnología sofisticada
es mucho más rara de lo que suponemos.
Después de todo,
sólo ocurrió una vez en la Tierra hace
4 mil millones de años.
Quizá incluso eso fue increíblemente fortuito.
Quizá somos la primera civilización
en nuestra galaxia,
o quizás
la civilización porta consigo las semillas
de su propia destrucción
en su incapacidad de controlar
las tecnologías que crea.
Pero hay numerosas respuestas
más prometedoras.
Primero, no buscamos con ahínco y gastamos
una cantidad irrisoria de dinero.
Sólo una diminuta fracción de estrellas
en nuestra galaxia
ha sido vistas de cerca en busca
de señales interesantes.
Y quizá no buscamos en el camino correcto.
Quizá cuando las civilizaciones se desarrollaron,
pronto descubrieron tecnologías de comunicación
mucho más sofisticadas y útiles
que las ondas electromagnéticas.
Quizá toda la acción ocurre dentro de la misteriosa
y recientemente descubierta materia oscura
o energía oscura, que parecen constituir
más de la masa del universo.
O,
quizá miramos con la escala incorrecta.
Quizá las civilizaciones inteligentes se dieron cuenta
que la vida en el fondo solo son patrones
complejos de información
que interactúan bellamente entre sí
y que eso puede suceder con
más eficiencia a pequeña escala.
Así como en la Tierra los voluminosos
sistemas de estéreo se encogieron
en bellos y pequeños iPods,
quizá la inteligencia misma,
para reducir su huella de carbón
en el ambiente, se volvió microscópica.
Entonces el Sistema Solar podría estar repleto de alienígenas y simplemente no los notamos.
Quizá las ideas mismas en nuestras cabezas
son una forma de vida alienígena.
Bueno, de acuerdo, esa es una idea loca.
Los alienígenas me hicieron decirlo.
Pero es fabuloso pensar que las ideas
parezcan tener una vida propia
y que trasciendan a sus creadores.
Quizá la vida biológica es solo una fase de tránsito.
Bueno, dentro de los próximos 15 años,
podríamos empezar a ver información espectroscópica real
de planetas cercanos que prometen revelar
lo amables que podrían ser.
Mientras tanto SETI (Búsqueda de Inteligencia Extraterrestre)
está publicando sus datos
para que millones de ciudadanos
científicos, quizás tú incluido,
puedan conjuntar el poder de las
masas en la búsqueda.
Y aquí en la Tierra, experimentos asombrosos
intentan crear vida de cero,
vida que podría ser diferente a las formas
de ADN que conocemos.
Todo esto nos servirá para entender
si el universo está repleto de vida
o si, en efecto, solo somos nosotros.
Cual sea la respuesta, a su manera,
es impresionante,
porque aunque estuviéramos solos,
el hecho de que pensamos, que soñamos
y hacemos estas preguntas
podría convertirse en uno de los hechos
más importantes del universo.
Y tengo una buenta noticia más que dar.
La búsqueda de conocimiento y
entendimiento nunca será aburrida.
No lo es, sino todo lo contrario.
Cuanto más sabes, más asombroso parece el mundo.
Y son las locas posibilidades,
las preguntas sin respuesta
que nos empujan a avanzar.
Que tu curiosidad persista.